[Musique]
Eric rimes bonsoir alors là attention
vous avez 38 ans vous êtes titulaire
d'une maîtrise de psychologie clinique
et de philosophie et vous êtes également
journaliste vous avez travaillé pour
guêpier libération Nova et vous avez
déjà publié deux livres je bande donc je
suis consacré au SM gay pendant les
années SIDA et le maître des amours qui
raconte votre expérience de masseur
prostituée bisexuelle attention aux yeux
maman va te coucher je te jure maman
c'est mieux alors voilà et vous publiez
aujourd'hui aux éditions blanches seriol
fucker journal d'un bare Baker
[Musique]
c'est une personne séropositive qui
désire avoir des rapports sexuels non
protégés avec d'autres barbe à coeurs
avec d'autres personnes séropositives il
y a aussi une forme plus radicale qui
est le barbacteur qui veut contaminer
les personnes séronégatives voilà moi
j'ai voulu un petit peu traiter tout ce
problème là
c'est vrai que à l'origine ça veut dire
chevaucher a cru en anglais américain
voilà ce qui veut dire baiser sans
capote en gros et alors dans la
communauté gay chez les barbeckers en
tous les cas il y a un véritable culte
des relations non protégées tout à fait
il y a les bonnes chasseurs c'est à dire
ceux qui désirent être affectés par le
virus et il y a les gifts giverse donc
c'est les donneurs de cadeaux et il y a
vraiment de plus en plus de personnes
qui ont des pratiques à risque les
statistiques sont exponentielles chaque
année en fait donc il y a ça il y a un
culte du sperme aussi
des muqueuses des glaires voilà et puis
aussi les rapports impersonnels
multiples
donc ça c'est vraiment la définition
complète du beurre Baker vous suivez
Astrid
S sont séropositifs comme vous alors les
barbeckers deviennent forcément à jour
ou l'autre séropositif c'est ça le
problème parce que c'est quand même une
maladie qui est grave et qui peut être
mortel voilà quoi donc il faut c'est un
peu le jeu de la roulette russe aussi
alors vous vous êtes devenus séropositif
à l'âge de 24 ans vous dites dans votre
bouquin prend de un premier x aller à la
gym se faire un tattoo devenir ses repos
c'est le parcours classique du jeune
[__] parisien normal moi mon livre c'est
un livre quand même radical donc il y a
beaucoup de phrases à l'emporte-pièce
c'est beaucoup de phrases un peu
humoristiques comme le sida parce que je
le vaux bien vous mûrir du sida que
d'ennuis donc c'est un humour très noir
très cynique c'est un roman assez
violent qui est assez dur à lire et qui
est pas évident et qui est un
documentaire assez exceptionnel pour ne
serait-ce que pour les hétérosexuels de
savoir comment les gays vivent
aujourd'hui
on a qu'une envie de se protéger
à contrario alors quand vous avez eu les
résultats de votre test quand vous avez
appris que que vous étiez positif vous
avez fait une tentative de suicide vous
êtes restés deux jours dans le coma et
quand vous êtes sortis de l'hosto vous
avez planté un couteau de cuisine dans
le dos de votre mari le couteau s'est
cassé vous êtes battu ensuite les flics
sont arrivés et vous terminez et voilà
c'est fini oui le coup de couteau en
plus c'est un couteau solide et par
chance si c'est cassé
en plus
ça fait pas rire non non ça me fait pas
rire mais non mais c'est super grave
ouais mais il faut moi je pense que
enfin si ça fait 14 ans que je suis
séropositif et que je suis encore en vie
c'est que c'est aussi que j'ai
suppositivé les choses et ne pas tout
prendre au dramatique et pouvoir en rire
et dans serial fucker j'essaye de rire
de tout et je pense qu'il faut rire de
tout comme on peut rire des [__] comme
on peut rire des Juifs aussi voilà par
exemple quand vous dites alors on peut
dire que c'est le personnage du roman et
que c'est pas vous mais quand vous
infectez sciemment un garçon qui
s'appelle Pierre sous prétexte qu'il est
con et prétentieux et que vous rajoutez
c'est un service à lui rendre pour
donner un sens à sa vie c'est quand même
excuse-moi c'est un crime de détraqué il
y a pas il y a pas d'autres mots les
moralistes mais c'est un crime c'est un
roman oui il a marqué roman
donc je dis pas que j'ai fait j'ai
pratiqué ces choses là tu de toute façon
il y a beaucoup de gens éventuellement
que j'aurais contaminé qui aurait été
contaminé ailleurs de toute façon donc
enfin ça vous est arrivé de faire
l'amour avec des gens négatifs en
sachant que vous pouviez les rendre
positifs par exemple si on veut rentrer
ensemble ce soir soit je vous ai dit que
je suis séropositif si vous ne voulez
pas qu'on mette des capotes je ne vais
pas en mettre le deuxième solution c'est
qu'on a pas parlé de mon état
sérologique sinon plus vous voulez pas
utiliser de capote moi je suis pas
responsable du désir que vous avez pour
moi ou pour d'autres personnes chacun
vous êtes séropositif si la personne me
le demande pas non parce que c'est la
personne de prendre ces responsabilités
aussi si on se protège pour soi je sais
que ça fait ça fait ça fait bondir tout
le monde moi je suis pas un monstre mais
c'est à chacun de se protéger pour
lui-même il y a aussi des gens qui
désirent contaminer les autres que ce
soit des hétéros ou des homos et le
personnage secondaire dans serial fucker
c'est une femme hétérosexuelle Nina qui
s'amuse à contaminer d'autres personnes
hétérosexuelles parce qu'elle a été
violée dans son enfance par son père et
voilà donc faut se méfier voilà c'est un
message aussi de prévention radical que
je fais
il y a une scène terrible avec un mec
marié
qui vient faire l'amour sans capote et
qui qui se fait infecter et en plus le
personnage ou vous j'en sais plus rien
mais vous dites je savais pas encore
pour ma rechute de syphilis donc le mec
il risque de se choper le sida et la
syphilis le même soir je sens que
j'entends que ça fait bon dire la salle
malheureusement vous savez qu'il y a de
plus en plus de barbecueurs qui en fait
ne pratiquent plus le sexe sans capote
parce que justement il se tape des
blennorragies des syphilis et d'autres
maladies quoi donc ils préfèrent ils
préfèrent éviter de d'avoir des rapports
de risque quoi il y en a un aussi qui
perd ses capotes c'est terrible ça ouais
alors ça c'est une rumeur c'est une
rumeur urbaine qui qui s'accule depuis
une quinzaine d'années et effectivement
ça peut exister c'est des trucs qu'on
voit sur Internet quoi donc les capotes
vaut mieux les vaut mieux les surveiller
quoi mais apportez les c'est aussi c'est
aussi valable pour les hétérosexuels
maintenant le premier groupe à risque ce
n'est pas les [__] qu'on soit clair le
premier regroupe à risque il y a 40 %
des gens qui sont hétérosexuels donc ça
concerne tes gamins ça son beau-frère ça
concerne vos parents c'est pas un truc
pour les [__] et les toxicos le cinéma
on vous raconter des trucs incroyables
dans ce bouquin par exemple les couples
qui quand il y en a un des deux qui
n'est pas assez repositif ils partagent
ils partagent le virus
complètement avec l'autre parce que
c'est vrai que pour avoir une sexe pour
être pour être dans une relation intime
une relation intime à long terme avec
préservatif c'est difficile à tenir et
c'est vrai qu'il y a plein de séries
négatifs qui par amour de leur
partenaire préfère devenir ces repos
effectivement est-ce que vous connaissez
des gens qui sciemment infectent des
gens qui sont séronégatifs par vengeance
par N de la société ou simplement parce
qu'ils sont positifs et ça les fait
flipper mais serial fucker moi je l'ai
écrit pour ça quoi pour pour montrer
qu'il y a des choses aussi radicales qui
existent quoi parce que le sida
j'ai entendu une histoire d'une gamine
de 18 ans
c'est une amie de ma petite filleule qui
a doit avoir 17 ans et effectivement il
y a un de ses potes qui a fait l'amour
avec une jeune fille qui a dit qu'elle
était vierge et en fait elle était
contaminée et elle lui a dit sciemment
que c'était pour manger quoi l'histoire
du premier rapport parce que quand on
est à 16 17 15 ans et qu'on a un premier
rapport sexuel on n'est pas du tout
habitué et là faut vraiment faire
attention quoi ça existe tu savais que
ça existait Francis
toi tu connais
au départ j'étais attaqué suite à mon
premier roman je bande donc je suis par
acte Paris qui ont fait des affiches
pendant la Gay Pride ou ils mettaient
que les bouquins de Guillaume du stand
et Éric raymmes étaient incité au
Barback donc ensuite on nous a traité de
criminels on nous a traité
d'irresponsables on nous a traité
d'assassin ensuite il y a même un
président dactop qui nous a traité de
Grenade sexuelle ce qu'avait fait
Jean-Marie Le Pen en nous traitant de
bons bactériologiques alors le problème
c'est que c'est les [__] système qui se
qui deviennent racistes enfin actes
Paris en l'occurrence donc moi j'ai
voulu faire un bouquin là-dessus et le
sida excusez-moi mais c'est quand même
un prétexte littéraire formidable le
barbacs ça touche à la vie à la mort au
désir à la sexualité à l'amour et c'est
quand même prétexte littéraire
formidable mais en même temps moi le
sida c'est pas une obsession littéraire
mon deuxième roman Le Master prostitué
il était séronégatif il y a pas que le
sida dans la vie non plus ok
on peut pratiquer le Light My Fire
ce qu'on fait on fait l'amour en fumant
à côté d'une bassine de kérosène
c'est la bombe mais il y a un truc
encore pire c'est le Buck cake donc on
vous a plu non mais ça c'est en fait
c'est un terme porno tu dois connaître
ça dans les les gang bang buccable
un grand spécialiste
je suis considéré comme une autorité en
la matière on prête pourri non c'est un
gangbang et là c'est un gang bang
buccable éjaculation faciale oui je
comprends pas le gang bangal excusez-moi
mais parmi Jagger ou machin enfin je ah
non il y a pas plusieurs en même temps
après l'autre
alors sérieusement là pour conclure
est-ce que vous pensez que vous êtes une
publicité formidable pour la capote ce
que je disais tout à l'heure ou au
contraire que vous allez donner à des
gens grâce à vos bouquins à vos passages
de la télé à la radio finalement des
idées terribles c'est-à-dire que au lieu
de sérieux le fucker claire c'est clair
c'est formidablement clair
son discours et pas tant bien sûr c'est
génial bien sûr c'est un écrivain avant
toute chose c'est noble littéraire
artistique quoi et moi ce qui m'a fait
ce qui m'a fait me radicaliser dans mes
positions c'est les attaques sur le fait
que il y a une espèce d'omerta dans le
milieu gay qu'on ne peut plus dire
certaines choses je suis sur la liste
noire de Têtu ils veulent pas parler du
bouquin parce qu'ils ont peur parce que
c'est les mêmes gens qu'a top donc il y
a une vraie omerta au moins la bouche la
seule librairie gay je suis vendu avec
un bandeau nous sommes en désaccord
total avec le contenu de ce livre
excusez-moi donc il y a vraiment une
forme de censure les [__] deviennent
totalement normatives
ils veulent avoir des gamins ils veulent
bientôt les [__] vont être aussi
j'allais dire aussi triste que les
hétéros alors que non mais non non mais
l'homosexualité l'homosexualité doit
rester quand même quelque chose de
subversif et de créatif sinon à quoi ça
on est loin de Jean-Jean
je n'ai quoi voilà le guide Michelin on
n'est pas obligé de grossir
oui c'est vrai
alors le sionisme explique à nos potes
donc vous allez nous expliquer un
entrepote là on est que des potes donc
on a une bande de potes vous allez vous
expliquer brièvement et simplement ce
qu'est le sionisme le sionisme d'abord
c'est le droit du peuple juif à
retourner sur sa patrie ancestrale qui
est devenu un état qui est attends
attends attends attends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça y est tout le monde est calmé pour
une fois ça vous concerne pas mon cher
klickman c'était acteur comme quoi tu
vois on s'attend s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît bien donc c'était acteur on
sait pas très bien pourquoi mais enfin
bon il y a de la peinture partout et ça
ressemble à du sang ça devient chaud
faire la télé maintenant
de personnes séropositives donc le but
de l'association c'est de lutter contre
le sida et de lutter aussi contre tous
ceux qui contribuent à la propagation de
l'épidémie
à travers ce que vous appelez entre vous
des apps c'est-à-dire des interventions
médiatiques pour vous faire remarquer il
y a eu ici sur ce plateau il y a 15
jours un zap parce que j'avais reçu
plusieurs fois d'ailleurs c'est vrai
dans rive droite rive gauche dans le
tribu et sur ce plateau un garçon qui
s'appelle Éric raymez et on va voir de
quoi il s'agit
c'est une personne séropositive qui
désire avoir des rapports sexuellement
protégés avec d'autres barbacs avec
d'autres personnes se repositives il y a
aussi une forme plus radicale qui est le
barbacteur qui veut contaminer des
personnes séronégatives voilà moi j'ai
voulu un petit peu traiter tout ce
problème là par exemple quand on vous
dites alors on peut dire que c'est le
personnage du roman il sait pas vous
mais quand vous infectez sciemment un
garçon qui s'appelle Pierre sous
prétexte qu'il est con et prétentieux et
que vous rajoutez c'est un service à lui
rendre pour donner un sens à sa vie
c'est quand même excuse-moi c'est un
crime de détraqué il y a pas il y a pas
d'autres mots les moralistes mais c'est
un crime c'est un roman oui il a marqué
roman
donc je dis pas que j'ai fait j'ai
pratiqué ces choses là tu dis toute
façon il y a beaucoup de gens
éventuellement que j'aurais contaminé
qui aurait été contaminé ailleurs de
toute façon
[Musique]
ça passe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien
ça y est tout le monde est calmé pour
une fois ça vous concerne pas mon cher
klickman c'était acteur voilà donc ça
c'était sur le plateau de Tout le monde
en parle il y a 15 jours effectivement
sur le moment j'ai compris que c'était
acteur mais j'avais pas du tout réalisé
que c'était en liaison avec l'invitation
de
Eric reymez donc qui je sais pas qui
soutient mais enfin qui fait la
propagande du barbeking
j'aurais pu vous le dire à ce moment-là
justement j'aime pas qu'on débarque sur
mon plateau sans me prévenir pourquoi
alors je vous pose la question très
simplement la victoire pourquoi ne pas
m'avoir appelé trois jours avant en
disant écoutez Ardisson vous inviter
rémess nous ça nous plaît pas du tout on
veut pouvoir venir le dire sur votre
plateau vous savez bien qu'ici on reçoit
des gens qui ont des avis extrêmement
différents vous savez bien reçoit Goupil
on reçoit Nabe et Dieudonné alors
pourquoi ne pas m'avoir appelé avant je
crois que les gens ont compris avec
l'extrait que vous avez passé le verbe
axe c'est donc un discours qui fait
l'apologie des pratiques à risque et qui
appellent à la contamination c'est ça le
berbach donc évidemment nous en une
association lutte contre le sida lutter
contre le verbach c'est un de nos
objectifs à partir de ce moment là
effectivement on fait tout pour que ce
discours soit le moins diffusé possible
avant que raymet soit invité dans
l'émission tribus on a eu toute la
production de votre émission on leur a
demandé de ne pas inviter des écrivains
berbère et vous les avez invités donc là
ce qu'on veut nous c'est pas c'est pas
passé à la télé c'est pas ça notre
objectif parce que ça va pas s'annuler
une fois que
Eric raymet a été invité une fois qu'il
a pu effectivement vendre son livre
l'effet est là et la question qu'on veut
enfin le problème qu'on veut poser c'est
le problème de votre responsabilité à
vous parce que c'est vous qui choisissez
vos invités c'est vous qui choisissez de
diffuser ce type de discours vous savez
les conséquences et vous savez que ça va
avoir des conséquences en matière de
contamination donc à partir de ce moment
là la question c'est la question de
votre responsabilité effectivement je
vais vous répondre moi je trouve que
dans cette émission on montre des choses
qui existent même si on n'est pas
toujours d'accord avec ces choses et je
pense que
montrer des gens qui pratiquent le
berberking c'est à dire des
séropositives qui baisent sans capote
pour être clair je pense que le fait de
dire que ça existe c'est une fonction
prophylactique c'est-à-dire que ça dit
aux gens mettez la capote encore plus
qu'avant parce que maintenant il y a des
cinglés vous avez bien vu j'ai dit
détraqué il y a des cinglés des
détraqués qui baisent sans capote donc
les mecs c'est comme ça donc moi le fait
de le montrer je suis je vous dis
franchement je cherche pas à me discuter
je dis franchement le fait de montrer
des berbacs pour moi c'est une façon de
dire méfiez-vous encore plus voilà et
vous vous dites c'est votre avis je le
respecte vous dites non il faut pas les
montrer du tout voilà ce que je vous dis
c'est que vous les montrer
systématiquement c'est à dire que
Guillaume Gustin qui a un autre écrivain
vous l'avez invité à chaque fois qu'il a
sorti un livre Éric
simplement il a dit sur votre plateau on
meurt plus du sidase qui est un mensonge
évidemment personne ne l'a repris donc à
ce moment là effectivement
Eric remet sort un livre personne n'en
parle dans la presse mais vous vous
l'invitez trois fois trois fois les
livres dont on parle pas c'est cela dont
je veux parler c'est pour ça que NAB est
sur ce plateau ce soir c'est pour ça que
plein de gens sont venus sur ce plateau
je pense que la démocratie c'est que
tout le monde puisse parler
mais seulement il y a plusieurs manières
effectivement de faire état du darbac et
le livre d'Eric rimès il s'agit pas
c'est pas un reportage c'est pas
présenter un état des lieux dire ça le
Berba voilà ça existe non c'est appelé à
la contamination notamment à la
contamination des militants d'accle
Paris par exemple et c'est faire la
promotion des pratiques aristes est-ce
que vous avez lu ce livre alors je peux
vous lire un passage vous me dites
simplement ce que vous en pensez
alors pour plomber quelqu'un je précise
plomber ça veut dire contaminer pour
plomber quelqu'un c'est également très
simple il suffit d'un peu de doigté de
patience et de subterfuge on retire
discrètement la capote pendant la baise
on fait semblant de la mettre des plombs
crèvent préalablement les capotes avec
une aiguille d'autres les sortes de
l'emballage et des couples réservoir il
la remettent ensuite ensuite on a la
description très très lente et très avec
beaucoup de plaisir de la contamination
d'un militant d'acteurs qui se termine
par j'ai plombé une acte Pienne j'ai
plombé une acte Pienne tralalala
tralalala
la mode a été vite répandue qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez j'en pense exactement
ce que je vous ai dit c'est à dire que
ça existe apparemment j'avais parlé avec
rémènes de cette idée de couper le bout
de la capote pour que le sperme puisse
passer évidemment et je trouve que le
fait complètement con mais je trouve que
le fait de dire que ça existe ça doit
inciter les gens à mieux porter la
capote voilà je suis désolé c'est ma
conviction je peux pas vous dire le
contraire mais vous diffusez vous
diffusez ce discours donc vous refusez
en vérité votre responsabilité c'est
simplement vous la responsabilité elle
est de dire au téléspectateurs faites
gaffe il y a des cinglés qui coupent le
bout des capotes pour filer le sida
d’autres gens encore une fois nous le
savait pas donc nous on l'a découvert
par votre émission ce qui a été je pense
un bon vecteur aussi pour vous parce que
le problème ça permet de faire une une
sorte de communication aussi pour votre
association mais notre but c'est pas de
sens
différentes non je crois pas qu'inviter
un écrivain qui fait l'apologie des
pratiques à risque ça soit une bonne
chose pour la lutte contre les gens
c'est ça je pense qu'effectivement il
faut de la prévention et expliquer
effectivement
l'information que la prévention ça
je crois que la prévention est efficace
je peux pas dire autre chose je crois
effectivement que la particularité de
l'épidémie de sida c'est que c'est une
épidémie qui se diffuse par des
pratiques et de l'information elle est
centrales ce qui est centrale c'est
diffusé la bonne information et pas
d'inviter des écrivains vers le coeur
comme le fait Thierry Ardisson
absolument systématiquement le problème
par ailleurs c'est que c'est une
émission de service public c'est-à-dire
que aujourd'hui la seule manière de
parler du sida effectivement c'est
d'inviter des écrivains berbecueil à ce
moment là effectivement c'est un
problème là-dedans parce que si sous
prétexte qu'on travaille dans le service
public on doit faire des émissions
consensuelles c'est plus le service
public ce qui est intéressant dans le
service public pardon mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est le public enfin à mon
sens c'est France Inter par rapport RTL
c'est France 2 par rapport à TF1 sur
cette liberté qu'on a d'inviter des gens
comme Dieudonné comme d'hab qui sont pas
politiquement corrects je pense qu'à une
époque personne voulait inviter Dieudo
il y a qui c'est qui pouvait parler naps
c'est pareil je pense que MS je
trouve ça dégueulasse je lui ai dit
qu'il était un détraqué mais le fait de
dire il y a des cinglés qui baisent des
séropos qui baisent sans capote je pense
que c'est une démarche profil active
voilà donc notre je vous demande pas
d'être d'accord avec moi je vous dis
simplement que ne vous méprenez pas je
n'ai aucune envie aucune envie de
propager le sida rassurez-vous mais je
pense que je pense que si un petit
scandale dans votre émission a pour
conséquence décontaminations et ensuite
des cadavres mais que ça vous fait
gagner quelques points de 10 matchs ce
n'est pas un problème je vous laisse la
responsabilité de vos accusations
cette émission fait 30% de parts de
marché régulièrement depuis des années
elle a pas besoin de scandale pour
continuer à réussir voilà quelque chose
je sais pas ce que la valeur que ça que
ça mais les gens aujourd'hui ont besoin
d'être choqués pour comprendre de plus
en plus malheureusement quand Guillaume
du stand a dit sur votre plateau on ne
meurt plus du sida personne ne l'a
contredit vous vous rendrez compte la
portée de telles propos aujourd'hui où
on sait que l'épidémie de sida par
ailleurs elle est en pleine reprise on
sait qu'il y a toujours pas de
prévention à l'école et vous laissez ces
propos justement là il y a un rôle de
service public effectivement je crois
que la prévention ça fait partie des
missions de service public
clairement les yeux dans les yeux
maintenant en parlant 5 minutes
d'acteurs c'est-à-dire il y a le livre
effectivement d'Éric cremès il y a le
livre d'Alain Soral aussi auquel vous
vous en prenez et alors là je voudrais
qu'on s'explique aussi vous avez saccagé
c'est à dire capteur est allé saccager
les bureaux d'un éditeur qui s'appelle
les éditions blanches qui sont dirigées
par
comme vous voulez des affiches sur les
murs d'une fusion d'édition
a été blessée elle a voulu empêcher une
pile de livre de tomber effectivement
elle a pris un livre je crois que six
jours mais les actions d'acteurs pour
ceux qui ont pu en voir sont des actions
absolument non violentes c'est-à-dire
qu'on s'en prend pas aux personnes il y
a 15 jours
ça a été extrêmement violent et j'en
suis vraiment j'en suis désolé parce que
c'est nous qui avons plutôt suivi les
coups mais on est une association non
violente la violence qu'on utilise c'est
une violence symbolique effectivement
coller des affiches dans une maison
d'édition prendre des livres sur des
rayonnages et les jeter par terre c'est
une violence symbolique mais c'est rien
par rapport à la violence qui est
exercée par ses propos deuxième action
d'acteurs vous avez saccagé le journal
20 ans
parce que Alain Soral il travaille donc
c'est dire aux gens qui emploient à l'un
Soral si vous continuez à employer à
l'instaural on viendra saccager vos
bureaux jusqu'à ce que vous l'employez
plus donc c'est une façon de le mettre
au chômage
le journal 20 ans a été zappé parce que
il y avait un article qui donnait toutes
les raisons de ne pas coucher avec
quelqu'un et parmi ces raisons il y
avait le fait qu'il soit séropositif
est-ce que quelqu'un a quelque chose à
dire dodo Zazie c'est difficile d'avoir
un point de vue parce que c'est vrai
aussi que moi j'ai été un moment donné
zappé à tort et j'ai essayé je suis venu
ici et j'ai eu une tribune pour pouvoir
m'exprimer et puis expliquer mon bon
problème donc je pense que c'est aussi
la chance d'avoir ici un endroit où tout
le monde peut venir s'exprimer donc
c'était toujours délicat et en même
temps tout le monde ne peut pas venir
qui ne peut pas venir s'exprimer non
dites-moi sérieusement victoire non
sérieusement dites-moi à part des
néonazis des mecs d'extrême droite des
fascistes que je ne recevrai jamais
parce que je suis dites-moi qui je ne
m'invite pas sur ce plateau sérieusement
dites-moi quel est le courant de pensée
qui ne sont pas invités ici dites en
matière de lutte contre le sida à part
les barbecueils depuis un an qui
avez-vous invité c'est vrai il faut
savoir une chose c'est que déjà illustre
contre contre un espèce de consensus
atroce qui considèrerait à penser que le
sida n'existe plus et qu'on attrape plus
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que c'est souvent des gens
qui sont sirop positifs au mieux c'est à
dire qu'ils sont confrontés au réel de
la maladie et que je pense que on est là
confronté à tout ce qu'il y a de
différence entre le réel et une
observation de la réalité qui est la
télévision je comprends le point de vue
de terre Ardisson je pense que en effet
malheureusement pour la plupart des gens
qui regardent la télévision c'est plus
parlant de voir
l'aberration de ce genre de pratique que
parfois les actes de des gens d'actope
je suis la première à trouver ça
absolument atroce on est dans un espèce
de consensus total mais
tant mieux si je veux dire acte peut
être là aussi pour dire attention le
combat n'est pas dans une témoignage de
la réalité mais dans un réel
les gens comme remet justement qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait parce que pour moi c'est
des criminels quand même qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait est-ce qu'ils vont en prison
est-ce que parce qu'ils sont là à visage
ouvert ils disent ça comme si c'était
une banalité mais c'est quand même une
démence totale c'est c'est de la c'est
du domaine du démon
de détraqué
c'est un crime mais seulement pour celui
qui écrit celui qui diffuse le discours
c'est-à-dire l'éditeur où vous n'a
aucune responsabilité et c'est ça qui
m'étonne dans votre discours vous ne
voulez porter aucune responsabilité sur
la diffusion alors que sans vous le
berbach n'existerait pas c'est-à-dire
que médiatiquement c'est vous qui avez
donné une audience au verbale on les
invitant systém atiquement vous savez
que vous vous retrouvez
s'il faut dire qu'il y a des
maisonnaises écoutez moi je vais vous
dire une chose après après je vais poser
une question sur acteur moi je vous
dirais une chose il y a deux théories
dans la vie il y a pas de liberté pour
les ennemis de la liberté et il y a je
ne partage pas vos idées mais je suis
prêt à mourir pour que vous puissiez les
exprimer moi je suis de la seconde
catégorie voilà j'ai pas ajouté quelque
chose je vous en prie allez je vous en
prie
je vous en prie je ne veux pas profiter
de mon statut d'animateur je discute
avec vous la liberté d'expression c'est
pas je dis quelque chose et ensuite je
m'en lave les mains donc la liberté
évidemment la liberté d'expression
a-t-elle pour mais aussi la
responsabilité de ses actes et la
responsabilité de ce qu'on dit moi je
vous dis que pour moi lutter contre la
propagation du sida ça passe aussi par
le fait de montrer des barbeckers vous
me dites NON je vous dis oui on sera pas
d'accord
sur la réalité de l'épidémie on va
terminer là-dessus je voulais vous
demander une simple chose à l'époque ou
acteur lutté par exemple pour que les
préservatifs soient vendus moins cher
pour qu'on trouve des préservatifs
partout moi j'étais un très grand
partisan d'acteurs ce que je comprends
moins aujourd'hui dans l'attitude
d'acteurs peut permettez-moi de vous le
dire victoire parce que vous êtes la
Présidente c'est quel est votre
légitimité pour donner des leçons de
morale
c'est à dire qu'est-ce qui vous
parlez-vous quel est qui êtes-vous pour
nous dire ce qu'on doit faire et pas
faire est-ce que le fait d'être
homosexuel donne un droit non ça ça
n'enlève pas des droits mais ça n'en
donne pas non plus alors notre
légitimité c'est que on est comme je
l'ai dit une association de malade on
est une association effectivement
issue de la communauté homosexuelle on
travaille maintenant depuis plus de 10
ans et je pense effectivement qu'on a
une légitimité sur la question du sida
pour et sur la question aussi de l'image
et des représentations parce qu'il faut
voir aussi le discours de la honte dont
on est sorti et Act-Up a contribué à
donner une visibilité aux malades à
donner aussi une image positive et c'est
pour ça que la question de l'image la
question des représentations qu'on donne
du sida et une question qui est
importante et je pense c'est pas des
leçons de morales mais c'est des
questions effectivement qui sont des
questions politiques si vous voulez mais
de politique d'urgence vitale pour nous
en tout cas moi ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que aujourd'hui tous les deux vous
m'avez convaincu que c'était une guerre
utile de se battre contre ce genre de
torche cul quoi c'est c'est comme ça
je l'ai invité
victoire
je crois que le berbach s'arrêtera au
moment où vous arrêterez les invités
de sa diffusion oui pour être sûr de ne
rien rater le Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu